- [Instructor] So I have two
different xy relationships
being described here.
And what I would like to do in this video
is figure out whether each
of these relationships,
whether they are either
linear relationships,
exponential relationships, or neither.
And like always, pause this video
and see if you can figure it out yourself.
So let's look at this first
relationship right over here.
And the key way to tell whether
we're dealing with a linear,
or exponential, or neither relationship,
is think about, okay,
for given change in x,
and you see, each time here,
we are increasing x by the same amount.
So we're increasing x by three.
So given that we're increasing
x by a constant amount,
by three each time, does y
increase by a constant amount?
In which case, we would be dealing
with a linear relationship.
Or is there a constant ratio
between successive terms
when you increase x by a constant amount.
In which case, we would be dealing
with an exponential relationship.
So let's see.
Here we're going from
negative two to five.
So we are adding seven.
When x increases by three,
y increases by seven.
When x is increasing by three,
y increases by seven again.
When x increases by three,
So here, it is clearly
a linear relationship.
Linear relationship.
In fact, you can even, relationship,
you could even plot this on a line
if you assume that these
are samples on a line.
You could think even about
the slope of that line.
For a change in x, for
a given change in x,
the change in y is always constant.
When our change in x is three,
our change in y is always seven.
So this is clearly a linear relationship.
Now let's look at this one.
Let's see.
Looks like our x's are
changing by one each time,
so plus one.
Now what are y's changing by?
Here it changes by two.
Then it changes by six.
Alright, it's clearly not linear.
Then it changes by 18.
Clearly not a linear relationship.
If this was linear, these
would be the same amount,
same delta, same change
in y for every time,
'cause we have the same change in x.
So let's test to see if it's exponential.
If it's an exponential,
for each of these constant changes in x's,
when we increase x by one every time,
our ratio of successive
y's should be the same.
Or another way to think about it
is what are we multiplying y by?
So to go from one to three,
you multiply, you multiply by three.
To go from three to nine,
you multiply be three.
To go from nine to 27,
you multiply by three.
So in a situation where every time
you increase x by a fixed
amount, in this case one,
and the corresponding y's
get multiplied by some fixed amount,
then you're dealing with an
exponential relationship.
Exponential.
Exponential relationship right over here.